before i moved in with george i was
living in a hotel
and one night i was really broke and i
went across the street there's a string
of gas stations
right so i'm living with before i moved
in with george
i think it was before i got the
apartment
with that lady when i was looking for
the apartment i stayed in fort lee for a
while because it's closer to the city
fort lee fort lee new jersey is right
across from manhattan on the bridge
they have all these hotels it's where a
comedy club called bananas is
if they ever ask you to play bananas
it's in it's right there on route 4
next to the bada bing that's why people
go to bananas because they go to the
bada bing
so i don't think it's still open it
doesn't matter but
one night i was staying at that hotel
and i was hungry
one afternoon and i crossed the street
to the gas station because that's how
much money i had
and i saw for help beside and i asked
the guy what are you looking for and he
goes
i need to marry pump gas from 4 to 12.
okay
where can i start he goes tonight he
goes what's your name i'm like
ryan sickler he's like lying
cichlid okay i see you at four o'clock
so i come back and i
realize i'm by myself so he trains me
for the first hour
in jersey and oregon they pump gas yep
still right
isn't it illegal to pump your own gas in
jersey that's crazy to me you gotta pump
gas and oregon still too
yeah i don't know but it is still jersey
2020.
i think in oregon they're just lighting
people on fire yeah you're right they
got a bigger problem
don't worry about the guy talking about
that that guy's pumping gas with a hook
right now
pumping gas on the crowd like the whole
fire crazy up there right now
so i went across the street and i'm
pumping all this gas
and he told me he goes it's like
nighttime so drop
every time you got 500 in your pocket
put an envelope
but what time sign this paperwork and
put a drop in there
i don't i didn't see the reason to you
know so every
hour like he told me i'd take like a
dollar bill and drop it
a dollar bill because for some reason i
computerized he goes i'll find that in
my house if you don't drop
so about [ __ ] two o'clock i realized
i got about twelve hundred dollars
plus what's ever in the register plus
the food
plus he's got a box of change under the
[ __ ] register
so i took everything i took everything
at three o'clock
hershey bars the whole [ __ ] thing and
i just walked across route 4
jumped over the [ __ ] banister in the
side of it cars were whizzing by me
doing 90.
and i went home the next morning i look
up i look out my hotel window
cops are there the whole thing people
have been pumping gas for free for four
hours
because i just left i just left i just
left
i just left right
so i figured this out but here's the
problem you got
you got a road gas station going that
way and you got a royal gas stations
going this way for me
that's a [ __ ] hit yeah so i wait like
three days sure enough i go to the gas
station
two doors down from that guy that [ __ ]
needs help
12 to 8. but here's the story the real
story was
my buddy worked at house yes i used to
get the chest
gas station he was the manager i still
talk to this guy he's still one of my
best friends in the world
so i told him to give me a list of
anybody who ever got fired for stealing
and he sent me a list of names so i
would apply under those names
so now i was smart the second time the
second time i went in there
what's your name tony ramirez where have
you pumped gas yes
where are we hawking yet when can you
start what do you got
12 to 8 i'm in i'd get there at 12 and
again
once i get a thousand that's it that's
it i put a dollar in the envelope
i just walk off even if i was working i
wanted to
you know even like you always working
with some guy and a jacket on
i'd say this i'm gonna go to the
bathroom
i did this every two gas stations then i
went across the street and worked myself
back
1200 1800 god it was always
something and that's that old-school gas
[ __ ] where you pulled the lever out of
the way
yeah there was none of that and then i
hung pie
gas means brian's sick was a broke [ __ ]
he comes and he gets four dollars worth
of gas
when lee comes in for gas guess who's
swallowing that four
liars that four is going right into
leaves i'm gonna put that thing in
without popping the thing back
come remember because you had to pop it
all right yeah you did but if you didn't
pop it all the way back and just put it
in there
the car would move up and then that make
believe it's already on four by the time
i'm putting it in right you're like i'm
making the first four dollars
this was hysterical i mean like yeah
hanging pumps that's what it was that's
what i mean my friends called it
hanging pumps so i would hang pumps not
only would i hang pumps i wasn't even
gonna pay for i wasn't even gonna pay
the gas man anyway
so i did that all around that gas
station
all the way back and then i took my then
i took my show on the road
and i took it down to south jersey and
i started hitting them all over south
jersey every day i take a bus
and it was hilarious i would take a bus
to a new area get out
see a gas station walk to three of them
and get hired by one
i go somewhere eat and stand there like
an [ __ ] for six
hours until i had to go back to four to
train because they take
can you start till they have four [ __ ]
yeah i'll start today at four
and i get back there at four o'clock i'd
pump gas till ten
i'd be working with some guy can i go to
the bathroom yes but hurry up
we're not running a chatter here all
right yeah good and i just go
sometimes i call george i would call
joyce i go george meet me there and ten
after nine
why ten after nine just be there at ten
after nine and
george would be there thinking he was
just picking me up coming off the bus
i get in the cargo hit it why
just hit it because i just robbed the
guy what are you talking about you
robbed the guy
i give him two bills he's 200 don't
worry about none so tell me what
happened so one time
i did this all over new jersey oh my god
this was hysterical
this is [ __ ] hysterical so now
i'm not going to tell you the name of
the place this is a huge gas station
like to pull this one off it was like
ocean's 11. you know what i'm saying
right
because they have like 18 gas guys
this place is huge like a truck stop
like a truck yeah
like let's just you know yeah sure
enough
[ __ ] boom the [ __ ]
they leave me from four to twelve and
it's non-stop
it's about to rain so i'm going from one
car to the other
three everybody twenties twenties tens
fifteens the [ __ ] thing is getting
thicker yeah
stacked my hands are filthy from all the
dollars
i'm handling they had to have four guys
on one island
you know just pumping doubles he's doing
big rigs and [ __ ] like that i'm doing
everything i'm doing everything i'm
pumping yeah no i
i wasn't doing diesel i was just doing
cars
so i'm doing cars i also in the [ __ ]
this sky is trying to turn gray
i'm doing cars i'm doing cars the sky is
starting to turn ground like
[ __ ] and i called george
and i asked the guy to go hold on can i
go make a call and i called george at
his mom's shop and he goes i can't get
to you
we got a special order man i'm sorry i
don't know what to tell you go [ __ ]
so i got like 2 000 in my pocket i'm
working and it's
about to rain but it was also
park and drive mm-hmm is that what they
call them park and ride where
people are you meet and get in one car
yeah
park and ride we used to have those all
over america there's buses that go into
new york from there
so sure enough park around looking at
these buses and they're lining up
and you get on any of them because
they're all going to new york and i see
all these people
so i got like two g's 2100 i go up to a
little [ __ ]
indian dude like you listen i gotta go
take a [ __ ] i got diarrhea huh
heady up with a busy mom can't you see
this i go yeah
and i dodged to the bathroom but i just
come out the side door
there's a ton of people and i just mixed
into the new york line
and i get on the bus and i'm watching
this [ __ ] guy
and this guy is pumping gas when he's
looking at the door to see if he sees me
he's pumping gas he's looking at the
door and after about five minutes i'm
getting that cheap my bus is i'm waiting
for the bus to fill
okay you're okay the guy's not gonna get
off until the bus fills up my god damn i
got on the wrong bus
i'm on the second bus and there's still
a bus in front of me
and now i see the guy go you know like
hold
on one second and he goes in there
looking for me
now i see the guy run out and like he's
like looking around for me
and he runs back to his little [ __ ]
friends and he's like you know he
and i'm watching all this go down and
often he runs into the office and he
gets on a [ __ ] phone
and they're [ __ ] calling somebody and
then they're all looking around and
another guy goes in there looking for me
and i'm telling the bus driver let's go
let's go
it's gonna [ __ ] rain and i mean the
[ __ ] scout
the skies are [ __ ] turning gray and
[ __ ] and they're looking around and
finally when my bus takes off as my bus
takes off they're all looking around
like where the hell does this guy go one
of them figured out
he's on one of those buses so i'm like
oh no
so as i'm pulling out of there i see
cops pulling in
oh [ __ ] i'm dead so bus pulls out i
figure they're going to arrest us when
we get in the poll authority
i get the port authority there's not a
cop inside
i walked out to broadway they didn't
stop you when you were leaving
nothing oh no [ __ ] nothing we didn't
stop them
we got on route 3 right to new york
i went i picked up george we took a
shower we got dressed and we went to
this
club in the city with another friend of
mine devo
and we went to the club and the
eurythmics were they're hanging out just
hanging out
like you couldn't even talk to them i
thought i was a [ __ ] big shot and
[ __ ]
but i stayed with and at that time i was
just doing creepy [ __ ]
how much would you say average you
probably hit in the gas stations at 1500
to 2 grand a pop
a pop yeah and about what does this
yeah like wow what's the biggest maybe
like it was like 2 400 and i had like 15
of them
but i had a thousand scams going i just
didn't want to stick to one scam i
wanted to throw enough spaghetti i would
do something for two weeks
then lay off it because i know now they
were hot for it
[Music]
you